that's one turnover
[Music]
that's got to go we've been talking mess
all day that he can score on meta look
at that up and look at you there's a
road we'll give you a little warm up on
this yeah yeah yeah there's zero chance
i would just i was i was the player of
the year i was in the bed but i heard so
now i'm here
[Music]
who going first raindrops
all i do is score
damn it
he's not even dressed up bro he's not
ready
you ready
oh that's one turnover
that was a fail
oh that's true
you got to figure it out we got to
figure it out
you got it
[Applause]
stop playing with me
[Music]
[Laughter]
no
hey mikey didn't think i was gonna get a
bucket but i didn't get one bucket i got
two against him
since you did that i'm about to change
my clothes oh
come on
my boy meta upgraded so i had to upgrade
you with some cobia
[Music]
we ready we rolling
that's one
that's one that's two
bro who do you think you are oh i'm not
worried about that one he turned his
back on you mikey
it's that way
oh no chance no chance that's a bag
though that's a bag how i got an open
look
champ god
you got four more he needs to go two for
four to go three for seven hold on i'm
going to somebody else somebody else do
the math he had enough
oh
[Music]
what time i miss nine in a row you get
one shot you can't choke don't be like
mikey flops
two one that's the bar two gotta score
more than two yo ocho's nice ocho is
nice
that's two
okay
one foot four one for four
buckets
one for nine
[Music]
this is a catastrophe hats off to greg
super sick super happy for you walked
out of here with some money meta
absolute legend craig craig's awful like
it just is what it is it's sad he's just
sad what did y'all expect
let's go
there we go
you got to get up
oh
come on
go away